We are here with Drew-Gooder, Jordan James,
the creator and host of "Good Deeds, Buffalo,"
a show dedicated to those who give back
and we were inspired by each other.
I would really like to introduce you
to someone who like you stopped at nothing
to achieve his dreams.
Please welcome the founder
and CEO of Hawke Media, Erik Huberman.
(audience clapping)
Hi Erik, how are you?
Good to see you.
Great to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
Thank you Erik.
Yeah.
Erik, I'm so fascinated by your company.
Thank you.
And will you talk to Jordan about what you do
and why you wanted to speak to him.
Sure, so run a company called Hawke Media
and we help brands all over the world grow.
We work with about 700 different brands
and came in touch with your story
and even what you were just talking about
and I was touched.
And so Drew reached out and asked me to help mentor you,
and as well as Hawke Media support you.
So we're gonna be spending time with you, working with you,
gonna be giving you a copy of my new book,
"The Hawke Method,"
and then also you've been through a lot
and so we want to give you $15,000
to help support what you're doing.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much.
Can I give you a hug?
Yeah, of course.
That's incredible.
Thank you.
I don't know what to say besides thank you so much.
Thank you for believing in me.
Thank you everybody in Buffalo
for believing in me.
And thank you, mom.
My mom's up there watching me right now
(audience clapping)
and I can feel her.
I can feel her motions and her power.
So thank you.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
I'm really excited also, you know,
not just money to go towards and support,
but some guidance and some ideas.
We all need some directions you know
with how to get our messages out there,
where to put them.
I mean business is complex
and there's a lot of different avenues
of how to navigate all of this.
Thank you for allowing me this.
Well, Erik, I look forward to your tutelage
and your wisdom and we'd like spread that.
It's gonna be wonderful to have somebody
who has more experience than I,
who I can go to I'm sure with questions
on how to do the best.
And thank you so much.
You'll have my cell, you'll have my email.
It'll be great.
Thank you so much.
And maximize and build and stay.
Yes.
(upbeat music)